dave chappelle tells the cancelers to
get lost the media unified to take down
facebook for platforming conservatives
and the educational experts admit
they're coming for your kids i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressivevpn.com
slash ben will get to all the news in
just one moment first reminder this is
your very last opportunity to get your
hands on a free signed copy of my book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps when you check out birch gold so
what are the reasons you should check
out birch gold i mean aside from getting
a signed copy of that book well the
number one reason is that inflation
continues to spiral out of control as
we'll discuss in just a little bit
inflation is expected well into next
year at this point and now democrats are
looking to push for trillions in more
spending they're hiding even how much
spending they are doing if you're
freaked out about the impact this
additional spending is going to have on
already high inflation now is an
excellent time to protect your savings
by reaching out to birch gold to
diversify part of your ira or 401k into
a precious metals ira go ahead and do it
today text ben 247 4747 get a free
information kit on protecting your
savings with gold i buy my gold from
birch gold they have an a plus rating
with the better business bureau
countless five star views thousands of
happy customers this month again when
you place an order with birch gold you
get that signed copy of my book how to
destroy america in three easy steps
which is just a little sweetener for
something you should probably be
considering anyway text ben 247 4747
claim you're free no obligation
information kit on holding gold and
silver in a tax sheltered account plus
sending this text is the only way to be
eligible for that signed copy of the
book again text ben to 47 47 47 and
protect your savings today alrighty so
we have now had in this country more
controversy over dave chappelle making
jokes about transness than we had over
joe biden completely surrendering an
entire country to the taliban which
shows you where our priorities are as a
nation
but dave chappelle for his part is doing
something quite important he's standing
up and he's just saying no and that's
really really important it's important
because most of the people who are
targeted by the woke cancel culture
crowd are not dave chappelle they're not
one of the most powerful comedians on
the planet who's worth a bajillion
dollars most people are people who are
targeted inside their organizations
people who are outed for some comment on
facebook people who have been ostracized
from their social circles and when they
see dave chappelle saying no they too
are empowered to say no because that's
the thing about the counselors you don't
have to be canceled if you don't want to
be canceled now that doesn't mean you
won't be fired it doesn't mean you won't
feel repercussions it does mean there's
a whole side of the aisle out here
waiting to embrace you if you decide
that you don't care whether you are
canceled or not by people who despise
you anyway so dave chappelle did another
comedy bit yesterday
and
in this comedy bit he explicitly talked
about meeting with the trans community
right this is something that many of the
people who were protesting him demanded
a meeting a meeting they needed a
meeting now i'm not sure what they think
would get done at the meeting other than
they would get to lecture chappelle and
they think what chappelle was going to
just sit there and apologize for his
jokes which comedians typically are not
in the vein of doing well chappelle did
another comedy set last night and he
addressed exactly this
complaint and demand
to the transgender community i am more
than willing
to give you an audience
but you will not summon me
i am not bending to anybody's demands
and if you want to meet with me i'd be
more than willing to but i have some
conditions
first of all
you cannot come
if you have not watched my special from
beginning to end you must come to a
place of my choosing
and a time
of my choosing
and thirdly
you must admit that hannah gatsby is not
funny
[Laughter]
i'm sorry like i'm sorry that he's funny
guys i'm sorry that he's funny and then
he's going to continue to be very
successful because he is funny now even
chappelle who is again the most
successful comedian on planet earth that
netflix plays and pays him just
oodles of cash in order to get him to do
his specials with them even chappelle is
now saying that he is at risk of being
de-platformed he says he produces
documentary and many of the major
distributors will no longer touch his
work other than his comedy specials
they're happy to make money off his
comedy specials but they're not going to
look at his ancillary work because he's
just too offensive here he was
discussing this
this film that i made was invited to
every film festival in the united states
and some of those invitations i accepted
and when this controversy
came out
about the close-up
they began disinviting me from these
film festivals and now
today
not a film company not a movie studio
not a film festival nobody will touch
this film thank god for teds randalls
and netflix he's the only one who didn't
cancel me yet
okay so he's uh thanking god for netflix
we'll see how long netflix lasts or
whether they choose to undergo this
controversy again and here's the thing
dave chappelle i'm sure that you and i
disagree on nearly everything i'm sure
that you have attacked people who work
with daily wire i mean i know you have
you've done it publicly with for example
candice owens i don't care i'd be happy
to work with dave chappelle i'm sure
canada owns would be happy to have dave
chappelle working over here too we don't
care because we are much more
open-minded than the left is when it
comes to jokes that target us again in
dave chappelle special he tells two
separate anti-semitic jokes no one seems
to care including me because the fact is
that while i don't like the jokes and i
don't really think they're funny
i am not the arbiter of what great humor
is i'm not the sole arbiter nor do i
feel that people ought to be silenced on
the basis of me not liking a particular
joke
so if he's looking for distributors who
are never going to cancel him he will
find himself on the right side of the
aisle sooner or later whether he likes
it or not because the left is just going
to continue
cordoning off all the areas where dave
chappelle is allowed to work there is a
great irony by the way in the fact that
the vast majority of people who are very
angry at dave chappelle or upper class
white liberals
you have a black man who's becoming
incredibly successful by telling jokes
coming from a background that was not
wealthy
and you have a bunch of upper-class
white woke liberals who are very very
upset at dave chappelle because he
noticed that a man is a woman that a man
is a woman is a nonsensical statement
because you notice that men are men and
women are women and human beings are
sexually dimorphous
like because you notice that the white
wolf liberals are very mad
any other situation where you had a
bunch of upper class white folks
attacking a black person it would be
totally unheard of it'd be really wrong
right and just another element of the
intersectional hierarchy of privilege
rearing its ugly head
but when it's dave chappelle telling
jokes about a a community that is
supposedly at the top of the
intersectional hierarchy of victimology
then dave chappelle must be brought to
heal so good for him for saying no on
all of that
as he pointed out he said i've been it's
been said in the press i was invited to
speak to the transgender employees of
netflix and i refused that's not true if
they'd invited me i would have accepted
it although i'm confused about what we'd
be speaking about i said what i said and
boy i heard what you said my god how
could i not you said you want a safe
working environment in netflix it seems
like i'm the only one that can't go to
the office anymore
and then he continued he said this
really isn't about the lgbt community
he says this has nothing to do with them
it's about corporate interest and what i
can say and what i cannot say
for the record i need to know this
everyone i know from that community has
been loving and supporting so i don't
know what all this nonsense is about
hey that i'm sure that is right by the
way i'm sure the vast majority of lgbtq
people who watch the chappelle special
are like
or they laughed or they don't care but
the activist class are the class that
run our media and run the corporate
board rooms so chappelle happens to be
right about that so it's very important
what chappelle is doing right now now is
it enough to
actually create a groundswell of
ignoring these folks
i doubt it
i mean he praises ted sarandos over at
netflix serendo's already offered a
quasi apology for aaron chappelle
special he said well yeah we should have
aired chappelle special but i should
have told the offended employees that i
understood their feelings and all that
that is always the prelude to the
alligator taking off an arm
netflix already fed them a finger
now it's just a matter of how far they
allow the alligator to go
whereas chappelle is cutting it off at
the beginning so good for him because we
need more of this in our society more jk
rowlings more dave chappelles again i
disagree i'm sure with jk rowling and
dave chappelle on nearly everything
but as i've said before the future of
this country and indeed of civilization
and freedom rests not with people on the
right who have already made our call
that we are in favor of individual
freedom nor does it lie with the radical
left which has made their call that they
don't care about individual freedom so
long as they are pursuing quote unquote
redistribute of justice
it lies in the middle with people who
may have sympathy for the agenda items
of the radical left but who believe that
individual rights take precedence and
that are forced to choose between
individual right and preservation of
their durability
and the agenda items of the left they
will choose individual rights and the
preservation of their durability even if
it takes longer to get to their policy
preference
already meanwhile speaking of folks who
are trying to shut down the pipelines of
information you've seen this coordinated
assault on facebook from the media and
it is truly coordinated
we've seen something like 17 newspapers
all releasing different parts of the
so-called facebook papers now from where
i said this is basically a nothing
burger facebook is a giant corporation
it does business
hundreds of countries around the world
it has billions of constituents
and it turns out that facebook's main
thrust when it comes to news or when it
comes to people talking with each other
is to not get in the way this has been
zuckerberg's position since literally
facebook started the difference is that
the media used to believe that and now
they no longer believe that now the
media are fully ensconced in the notion
that facebook should shut down the
information the media don't like
as i've been discussing for a while here
now there is an elite codery in the
media that felt that it could
monopolistically dominate the
dissemination of information
and for most of the 20th century they
were right you had three news networks
abc nbc cbs
the third one of those only cropped up
much later in terms of its serious tv
presence
you had radio networks which were also
dominated by just a couple of
corporations you had a couple of
nationally distributed newspapers and
then you had your local newspaper that
was it
there were no other means of
dissemination of information and so for
a long time that oligopoly of
information
prevented the american people from
seeing the truth behind their
institutions which is that most people
who are on most institutions are idiots
because most people you know are idiots
at the beauty of a free market is that
the idiotic parts of what you do during
your day
are kind of
shuffled out right they
basically there's the wheat to your day
and there's the chaff to your day right
the wheat being the productive part of
your day and the chaff being the
unproductive part this is true for all
decision making what the markets do is
they focus in on the wheat and they
maximize the wheat i can't trade my
chaff for your wheat useless stuff that
i do the bad decisions i make that is of
no value to you so i can't trade by
chaff for the productive stuff you do i
can only trade the productive stuff that
i do for the productive stuff that you
do what markets do is incentivize good
decision making
okay our institutions so what that means
is that a free market allows for a lot
of idiocy right we can all individually
be idiots but our collective knowledge
about our own situations is much higher
than any one centralized source of
information
and all the people around you might be
adults but you can still work with each
other because you understand what that
guy over there that idiot he has one
productive thing he does all day and his
fixed car so you know to bring your car
to him when you want your car fixed but
you're not gonna take life advice from
that guy okay so you can survive in a
free market system understanding that
most people are kind of dumb
what you cannot do is centralize all
power in institutions
with the same dumb people at the heads
controlling all aspects of your life
doing all the all the things that make
them done are now part and parcel of
what you have to accept from them okay
and this was the great lie this is the
lie from the beginning of the
progressive era is that if you give
power to the so-called experts many of
whom happen to be idiots
then they will fix all of your problems
and the media were fully in line with
this because they too then got to be the
great expositors they got to be the the
most powerful informational mind-shaping
people on planet earth problem is they
too are idiots so when the 20th century
came to a close and the internet started
to rise and suddenly
the oligopoly was broken and suddenly
you could actually see behind the
curtain
instead of americans reacting by saying
okay well maybe we should take power
away from the institutions the
institutions reacted and they made
americans face each other and they said
okay well we're not the problem you're
the problem
and so you
you uninformed rubes the big problem is
that you're you've got too much access
to the information you've seen behind
the curtain and you must never see
behind the curtain again we must
foreclose your ability to access
information
the original thought of a lot of these
elitists in our society
was that the rise of the internet would
facilitate all sorts of conversations
that would ensconce them in power that
would re-enshrine their power
and then it turns out that when people
saw behind the curtain their first
reaction was whoa
has it always been like this has it
always been this dirty and this ugly and
the answer is yes it's always been the
sturdy it's always been this ugly the
difference was these people didn't have
that much power over your life then over
the course of an entire century they
took tremendous control over your life
but they were still the same idiots and
now we see they're idiots
but those idiots have to maintain their
power somehow the way they've chosen to
maintain their power is to now shut off
the spigot of information
right to
re-institute their oligopoly their
control over what you can see and what
you can hear because here's the problem
when it comes to assessing your own
rights when it comes to assessing your
own place in the world and who should
control you you're not an idiot
you're actually pretty good at this part
but they don't like that because you
might come to a conclusion different
than the conclusion they have for you
this is why they've been so angry that
people are able to go online and get
information and make their own risk
assessments with regard to covet for
example it's why they're so mad that
people have been able to go online and
actually view stories about hunter biden
and corruption inside the biden family
it's why the people who are the
oligopoly they understand that every
time the institutions that they have
built up crack they're that much closer
to crumbling and so they're going to
shore them up with the cement of
censorship that's what these facebook
papers are about they're not about
making facebook better they're about
making facebook more closed
because they care about the internet
becoming more closed because they want
their control we'll get to this in just
one second first let's talk about
another podcast you should give a listen
to that is the jordan harbinger show
it's a podcast you should try out i know
every day somebody tells you that you
should listen to another podcast you're
like i don't have time for another one
this one you should make time for
jordan's show which apple named one of
its best of 2018
is aimed at making you a better informed
more critical thinker so you can get a
sense of how the world actually works
and come to your own conclusions about
what's happening even inside your own
brain each episode is a conversation
with a different fascinating guest and
when i say there's something for
everyone here i mean it it's it's always
eclectic and fascinating jordan talks
for example to a hostage negotiator from
the fbi in one episode who offers
techniques on how to get people to like
and trust you another episode tells the
story of a pimp and mafia enforcer who
talks about my manipulation techniques
or i mean it's it's weird and
interesting and offbeat and you'll
always learn something i recommend our
listeners check out jordan's
conversations with colonel oliver north
or kobe bryant i don't always agree with
jordan but you don't have to learn
something we here at the dailywire enjoy
the show we know you will too check out
jordanharbinger.com
start for some episode recommendations
or search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h-a-r-b as in boy i n is in nancy
g-e-r on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts okay so
the big breaking news from facebook
is is via the wall street journal quote
facebook internal chat boards show
politics often at center of decision
making
in june 2020 when america was rocked by
protests over the death of george floyd
at the hands of a minneapolis police
officer a facebook employee posted a
message on the company's racial justice
chat board get breitbart out of news tab
news tab is a feature that aggregates
and promotes articles from various
publishers chosen by facebook the
employee's message included screenshots
of headlines on breitbart's website such
as minneapolis mayhem riots and masks
massive looting buildings in flames
bonfires and blm protesters pummeled
police cars on 101.
the employees said they were emblematic
of a concerted effort at breitbart and
similarly hyper-partisan sources none of
which belong in news tab to paint black
americans and black lead movements in a
very negative way according to written
conversations on facebook's office
communication system reviewed by the
wall street journal many other employees
chimed in to agree
in the same chat a company researcher
said any steps aimed at removing
breitbart a right-wing publisher popular
with supporters of former president
trump could face roadblocks internally
because of the potential political
blowback at best it would be a very
difficult policy decision the researcher
said
facebook chose to keep breitbart on news
tab a spokeswoman for the tech giant
said the company makes a judgment based
on the specific content published on
facebook not the entire breitbart site
and that the facebook material met its
requirements including the need to abide
by its rules against misinformation and
hate speech
many republicans from mr trump down say
facebook discriminates against
conservatives the documents reviewed by
the journal didn't render a verdict on
whether bias influences its decisions
overall they do show that employees and
their bosses have hotly debated whether
and how to restrain what right-wing
publishers with more senior employees
often providing a check on agitation
from the rank and file
the documents viewed by the journal
which don't capture all the employee
messaging didn't mention equivalent
debates over left-wing publications okay
so
is this a
leak that paints a bad light on facebook
what this leak actually shows is that
the facebook higher ups were demanding
that employees show where breitbart was
wrong in their headlines because none of
those headlines were false cities were
burning last summer people were
pummeling police cars on the 101 last
summer there's video that was attached
to all of these articles
but some facebook employees were mad
they were mad because facebook was
allowing too much speech because as our
left-wing oligarchs suggest
too much speech allows for the rubes to
actually view things they shouldn't be
viewing and we have to restrict what the
rubes can see and what the rubes can
hear and if we close their eyes when we
close their ears then they will speak
the words we want them to speak namely
the nostrums of the democratic party
now facebook for its part
didn't remove breitbart news from that
news tab what they have done and we've
talked about this on the show before is
they've taken soft measures to reduce
the reach of right-wing content on their
site
we know this because we can see our own
internal metrics
right bart their traffic got taken down
20 percent that is because of interior
agitation at facebook promoted from the
outside by the media because guess what
the new york times loves when facebook
shuts down right-wing speech
right when speech competes with them see
the media has been faced with a real
problem as one of the institutions that
has been proved to not be competent at
their jobs which was to just provide you
the fact
as an institution that has lost trust
with the american people they have two
choices one is they could look in a damn
mirror
and recognize that the rise of
right-wing publishers is a direct result
of the lack of institutional trust in
them that would require them to change
their business model it might require
them to hire somebody who for example
voted for president trump in the last
election cycle
i i'm not certain that there's one
member of the editorial page board over
at the new york times for example who
voted for trump i'm not aware there are
any
okay that that might require them if
they wanted to take seriously the needs
of the readers
it might require them to get outside
their box or alternatively they could
just look to facebook and noticed that
they aggregated all the eyeballs and
then just tried to strangle all the
information that wasn't coming from the
new york times and re-establish their
monopoly
according to the wall street journal
facebook employees as seen in a large
quantity of internal message board
conversations have agitated consistently
for the company to act against far-right
sites
in many cases they've framed their
arguments around facebook's enforcements
of its own rules alleging that facebook
is giving the right-wing publishers they
pass to avoid a pr blowback as one
employee put it in internal
communication we're scared of political
backlash if we enforce our policies
without exemptions except that that's
not policy enforcement you have to point
out where breitbart was lying in order
to get them banned
it's never about policy enforcement it's
specifically about the fact
that these employees don't like
breitbart or don't like daily wire
okay that's what this has always been
about
a cnn reported for like weeks that
joe rogan was taking horse dewormer he
was not
they maintained that he was taking
horsey warmer he was not
has cnn been dinged by facebook on any
of that of course not
the facebook employees aren't in control
of the company and this is what they're
angry about so they went outside the
company to try and gain control of the
company that's what this this so-called
whistleblower who really is just
a ridiculous left-wing activist
attempting to grab control of the reigns
of power herself that's what she is
doing it's the reason why democrats are
upholding it why do you think that these
specific documents were leaked not to
places like daily wire or daily caller
or breitbart why do you think they were
leaked to all of the legacy media
outlets because the legacy media elite
are in on it the legacy media outlets
love it anything that reestablishes
their stranglehold on information is
good for them so this facebook former
employee went to a pr manager and they
tranched out these really non-revelatory
documents to a bunch of outlets that are
sympathetic to the idea that facebook
needs to stop disseminating information
that is not the legacy media outlets
it's a power grab it's that simple it's
not about principle it's simply about
power as always
alright so according to the wall street
journal
facebook employees focused special
attention on breitbart the documents
show criticizing facebook for showcasing
the site's content in news tab and for
helping it sell ads they also alleged
facebook gave special treatment to
breitbart and other conservative
publishers helping them skirt penalties
for circulating misinformation or hate
speech
right-wing sites are consistently among
the best-performing publishers on the
platform in terms of engagement
according to data from newswhip that is
one reason facebook is often criticized
by people on the left who say facebook's
algorithms reward far-right content
facebook says it enforces rules equally
and doesn't consider politics in
decision making facebook spokesman andy
stone said quote we make changes to
reduce problematic or low quality
content to improve people's experiences
on the platform not because of a page's
political point of view when it comes to
changes that will impact public pages
like publishers of course we analyze the
effect of the proposed change before we
make it
now again the the goal here with this
entire
tranche of stories from the media are to
push facebook to do more censorship this
is why when you hear people on the right
they're like yeah facebook does a bad
job because they are censoring right
wing speech there's truth to that there
really is i mean again i know the
internal metrics
there's truth to the notion that they
have specifically targeted right-wing
sites by changing policies like for
example the people who are the most
engaged they have prevented those people
from having their engaged posts reach a
lot of people
they've also changed the the way that
the stories are distributed by measuring
how much of a site's traffic comes from
facebook if too much of a site's traffic
comes from facebook they ding the site
and they reduce its reach
which of course benefits legacy media
outlets like the new york times or cnn
which have existed for a much longer
time and have been able to gain market
share long before facebook arrived
right so it is simply true that facebook
has dinged right-wing traffic
this is well known in the industry
but when the wright complains about that
and then they say we can make common
cause of elizabeth warren and the left
no you guys have diametrically opposed
solutions the right says facebook needs
to open up more and allow more speech
and leave us alone and the left says you
must never leave the right alone you
must shut down all of those sites and
then they use all sorts of ridiculous
jerry-rigged studies
in which they penalize you for openly
stating your bias so for example if you
go to newsweb newswhip will say that my
site the daily wire
is ranked less lower on trust than for
example cnn or the new york times why do
they say that we literally had a call
with them and on this call with newswhip
we explained we are overtly conservative
and they said right but that means
you're biased and we said well actually
it means we're honest
and we're overtly conservative and i
said well this means you're less trusted
it's like hold up so if we're honest
about our own bias whereas the new york
times lies
clearly and openly about its own bias
they're considered more trusted and
they're considered more honest
we label every one of our stories at the
bottom of the story it says that we are
a conservative news site
and this makes us less honest than the
new york times which just lies about
things routinely because of its
left-wing bias
so facebook tends to use studies from
outside groups like newswhip or they
tend to use the fact checks of
politically motivated groups like
politifact in order to ding right-wing
publishers this is the entire goal
breitbart was included in the news tab
which was launched in 2019 according to
the wall street journal the product
contains a main tier with curated news
from publishers including the wall
street journal new york times and
washington post those get paid for their
content right all of the big guys are
already getting paid directly by
facebook daily wire is not paid directly
by facebook breitbart is not paid
directly by facebook breitbart is part
of a second tier of news designed to
deliver news tailored to a user's
interest it is not paid
facebook said it requires sites included
on newstab to focus on quality news
reporting and bars those that repeatedly
share what it deems misinformation or
violate its public list of community
standards
asked about the inclusion of breitbart
mark zuckerberg said at the time of the
launch that the aim was for news tab to
have a was for news tab to have a
diversity of perspectives
one staffer wrote in the racial justice
chat he understood factual progressive
and conservative leaning news
organizations both needed to be
represented both needed to be
represented but that could be done
without including breitbart
again this is the game the game is
re-establish
the monopoly reestablish the monopoly
and again the way that they crack down
most on the
on the conservative publishers
the way they crack down most is they put
in place tools that are specifically
designed to only hit conservative
publishers
so they for example looked at their
informed engagement and sparing sharing
tools
and then they used those metrics and
they triggered those metrics to lower
right-wing traffic
and the idea is that they're a pro
right-wing site according to these folks
again it's all about the control it's
all about and they're just saying
ridiculous things i'm sorry
is it the town square's fault if people
use the town square in a way that you
don't like
in essence the argument against facebook
allowing distribution of information is
the argument against the first amendment
so oliver wendell holmes famously wrote
in a descent in a case in the early 20th
century that when we discover that there
are people of many fighting faiths
who have to argue with one another and
that that argument allows the truth to
out
that view on the first amendment has
been completely rejected by the left
the first amendment according to the
left is a problem and the reason it's a
problem is it allows people to say
things you don't like
we need to lower the risk that people
might believe things you don't like by
lowering the ability to hear things via
the first amendment they believe this on
a broad level and they believe it on a
narrow applied level over at facebook
and so what you do is instead of blaming
the people who pervay misinformation for
purveying this information and calling
it out instead you blame the fact that
there is a first amendment or that there
is a facebook this is why you see the
ridiculous specter of francis hogan the
so-called facebook whistleblower who
again is just a left-wing activist who
is revealing essentially nothing new
going in front of british lawmakers and
saying that in 60 years there will be
women walking around with brittle bones
because of choices that facebook made
now or maybe they'll be walking around
with brittle bones because of choices
they make now i'd notice that facebook
doesn't do anything except allow people
to see information
i'm extremely worried about the
developmental impacts of instagram on
children beyond the fact that if you get
an eating disorder when you're 16 you
may have osteoporosis for the rest of
your life right they're gonna be women
who are walking around this earth in 60
years with brittle bones because of
choices facebook made now
because of facebook not because of their
parents
not because teenagers are making
decisions that are bad all the time
because of facebook
by the way she was honest about this
like a few weeks ago she said that she
wishes that there was an oversight body
that she was the head of so basically
she doesn't like how zuckerberg's
running a place so she wishes to run the
place and you see that the again
facebook must be blamed for everything
so facebook was blamed in the immediate
aftermath of donald trump winning the
2016 election the media quickly shifted
from hillary clinton was a bad candidate
two it was the russians in facebook that
won donald trump the election and so
they're really really bad
and now they're trying to blame facebook
for january 6th
right so the beginning they blame parlor
and they knock parlor offline now
they're blaming facebook because hey
look a convenient target
so for example you have cnn reporting
quote not stopping not stopping stop the
seal
facebook papers paint damning picture of
a company's role in insurrection
just days after insurrectionist stormed
the capitol on january 6th facebook's
chief operational officer sheryl
sandberg downplayed her company's role
in what had happened we know this was
organized online we know that she said
in an interview with reuters we took
down q and boys stopped the steal
anything that was talking about possible
violence last week our enforcement's
never perfect i'm sure there are still
things on facebook
but internal facebook documents reviewed
by cnn suggest otherwise the documents
including an internal postmortem and one
document showing in real time counter
measures facebook employees were
belatedly implementing paint a picture
of a company that was in fact
fundamentally unprepared for how the
stop the steel movement used its
platform to organize and that only true
and and that only truly swung into
action after the movement had turned
violent
asked by cnn about sandberg's quote a
facebook spokesperson pointed to the
greater context she'd been noting that
january 6th organization happened
largely online including but now limited
to facebook facebook's platforms the
spokesperson said
one of hogan's central allegations about
the company focuses on the attack on the
capital in an sec disclosure she alleges
quote facebook misled investors and the
public about its role in perpetuating
misinformation and violent extremism
relating to the 2020 election and
january 6th insurrection
facebook denies the premise
they say quote the responsibility for
for the violence that occurred on
january 6 lies with those who attacked
our capital and those who encouraged
them we took steps to limit content that
sought to delegitimize the election
including labeling candidates posts with
the latest vote count after mr trump
prematurely declared victory pausing new
political advertising and removing the
original stop the steel group in
november
but again the idea is that if facebook
didn't stop every bad thing from
happening facebook must be stopped
itself and the person who should be in
charge is francis hogan who will stop
all bad things from happening how by
giving her and her friends total control
this is not whistleblowing it's just a
power grab as always
as always
and the media are pushing at full scale
i mean it's pathetic the washington post
has an entire piece titled quote you've
decided to quit facebook here's how to
migrate your online life elsewhere
okay so again they're just encouraging
people to quit facebook
listen if you want to not be on facebook
your prerogative but let's not
let's not pretend that this is anything
but a coordinated hit designed to
destroy conservative publishers by
forcing facebook into compliance with
left-wing demands
for his part zuckerberg did an earnings
call in which he said what we're seeing
is a coordinated effort to selectively
use leaked documents to paint a false
picture of our company
he said the reality is these questions
are not primarily about our business but
about balancing different social values
this of course is correct he is right
about this
but you have to understand that the
institutions will not let go of their
power they won't anything that
disseminates power more broadly anything
that opens up is a threat to the new
york times it is a threat to cnn it is a
threat to the democratic party
that's a threat you are a threat you
having information is a threat
and so whenever you see a story about a
shark
basically the blood in the water and the
sharks coming for a company like
facebook
understand it's not really directed to
facebook it's directed at you it really
is because that's that's the angle
that does not say facebook has handled
this perfectly again we've been dinged
by facebook we've lost traffic for no
reason on facebook and we're pretty
pissed about it
but the overarching attack here from the
left is designed to prevent you from
viewing shows like this one it's
designed to get companies like youtube
to take down content that you like
that's the goal in just one second
speaking of the attempt to maintain
control over you and your life and your
children remember that time left said
they weren't teaching critical race
theory and that they were not teaching
radicalism now they're like even if we
are you need to shut up about it first
if you haven't heard already the daily
wire has signed allison williams to lead
a very special sports series exclusively
for our members allison was a seasoned
sports reporter for espn she announced
her resignation last week because they
were trying to force her to get the kova
19 vaccine despite the fact that she
already had natural immunity and was
looking to get pregnant well her
decision to leave didn't go unnoticed by
us instead we decided to pick her up and
now she'll be making great content for
us we uncancel the cancelled here at
daily wire left to see lead us do not
dictate our content you do you decide
what you want to watch and which
creators to support if you want premium
entertainment and sports content without
the woke become a member at
dailywire.com subscribe use code do not
comply at checkout for 25 off we're
building a movement against the leftist
hollywood machine and joe biden's
unconstitutional mandates but we need
your help so go to dailywire.com
subscribe code do not comply for 25 off
help us we really needed it join the
fight also there's no better way to wake
up than with your daily dose of the
facts which is why the daily wire
created morning wire the daily morning
show dedicated to bringing you all the
news you need to know with no spin or
hidden agenda it's the only daily
podcast that values your time and the
truth and while we are working overtime
to make sure fact-based news still has a
platform we do need your help to keep it
trending toward number one so subscribe
start listening now to morning wire on
apple spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts leave a five-star review if you
like what you hear you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so as i say there are people
who want to control you they want to
control your right to see information
they would also love to control how you
raise your kids there's a piece
in the washington post it was retweeted
by the american federation of teachers
had randy weingarten who's one of the
worst people in america i mean her her
absolute scorn for the parents of
america is truly astonishing
okay she retweeted this piece the piece
is titled quote parents claim they have
the right to shape their kids school
curriculum
they don't
um yeah we do actually it's written by
jack schneider an assistant professor of
education at the university of
massachusetts lowell and jennifer
berkshire a freelance journalist and
co-author of a wolf at the schoolhouse
door the dismantling of public education
in the future of school
and the idea is that only school boards
only government actors only the wise
will determine how your children are to
be educated now what's kind of amazing
about this is that the rise of the
public education system in america if
you actually look back historically
was
not particularly a bad thing but it also
was kind of an anti-catholic thing if
you look at how public schools were
supposed to
operate they were almost designed to
operate as anti-catholic indoctrination
centers and people talked pretty openly
about this at the time so from the very
beginning there's been open debate about
how kids are to be taught in schools and
whether schools are simply supposed to
convey reading writing and arithmetic or
whether they're supposed to impose
values
but parents have always had the ability
to take their kids out of school to
homeschool their kids
but the left would like this not to be
the case
i recently did a discussion slash debate
with anna kasparian of the young turks
and she openly said that she would love
the finnish model in which there are no
private schools and homeschooling is
foreboding
in which basically you must send your
kids to a government indoctrination
center well that's the underlying case
here in the washington post
in their search for issues that will
deliver congress in 2022 conservatives
have begun to circle around the cause of
quote unquote parents rights in indiana
republican attorney general todd rokita
recently introduced a parent's bill of
rights which asserts that education
policy and curriculum should actually
accurately reflect the values of indiana
families in le in florida the
legislature passed an even more
comprehensive bill assuring that the
state and its public schools cannot
infringe on the fundamental rights of
parents
given this frenzy one might reasonably
conclude that radicals are out to
curtail the established rights that
americans have over the educational
sphere yet what's actually radical here
is the assertion of parental powers that
have never previously existed
this is not to say that parents should
have no influence over how their
children are taught a common law and
case law in the united states have long
supported the idea that education should
prepare young people to think for
themselves even if that runs counter to
the wishes of parents
in the words of legal scholar jeff
shulman this effort may well divide
child from parent not because socialist
educators want to indoctrinate children
but because learning to think for
oneself is what children do except
that's not what you're talking about
it's not about children learning to
think for themselves it's about parents
wanting their kids to have their values
and to pass their values onto their kids
it's literally my number one priority in
life
and about educators who have a different
set of values this is not a
value-neutral proposition
okay which is the reason why i pick
where my kids go to school and i
specifically
ask the principals where my kids go to
school if my kids are being taught
values that i agree with and i will not
send my kids to a school where the
values that i agree with are not taught
when do the interests of parents and
children diverge according to these
columnists generally it occurs when a
parent's desire to inculcate a
particular worldview denies the child
exposure to other ideas and values that
an independent young person might wish
to embrace or at least entertain
to turn over all decisions to parents
then would risk inhibiting the ability
of young people to think independently
as the political scientist rob reich has
argued quote minimal autonomy requires
especially for its civic importance that
a child be able to examine his or her
own political values and beliefs and
those of others with a critical eye if
we value that and the structure of
schooling cannot simply replicate in
every particularity the values and
beliefs of a child's home
the law has long reflected this consider
homeschooling although it is legal
across the country states still regulate
its practice such regulations aren't
often enforced but they are certainly on
the books homeschooling parents can be
required to establish minimal minimal
academic qualifications to submit
examples of student work to school
district administrators or even to adopt
a state-approved curriculum
the sudden push for parental rights then
isn't a response to substantive changes
in education or the law it's a political
tactic
and then they say that it's a paranoid
style of politics quoting richard
hofstede or one of the most overrated
historians of the 20th century talking
about how it's just paranoid to think
that these people want to indoctrinate
your kids
they have no political values they just
want you to have kids who challenge
everything that you believe
in framing our public schools as
extremist organizations that undermine
the prerogatives of families
conservatives are bringing napalm to the
fight that may rally the base and tilt a
few elections in their favor but as with
any scorched earth campaign the cost of
this conflict will be born long after
the fighting stops parents may end up
with a new set of rights only to
discover they have lost something even
more fundamental in the process turned
against their schools and their
democracy they may wake up from their
conspiratorial fantasies to find a pile
of rubble and a heap of ashes
this was retweeted again by the american
federation of teacher's head
but you shouldn't worry about the fact
that they are teaching your kid radical
crap in school
and the school library is filled with
pornography which is actually the case
in loudoun county for example no what
you should actually
worry about is your own authoritarian
fascism in wanting your kids to be
inculcated with your values
okay so the plan is to hijack your kids
i mean they're openly saying that the
plan is to hijack your kids and that you
really should have no say in the matter
i mean it makes sense on a sort of
demographic level right there's one
group in the united states that is
having lots of kids namely religious
parents there's another group that is
having almost no kids namely highly
secularized parents and highly secular
people in the united states are having
very very few children at this point and
people who are religious are having lots
of kids which means that down the line
if parents actually teach their kids
their values and those kids live with
those values you're going to get a more
right-wing more religious country life
doesn't like that very much so one of
those solutions is take those kids and
indoctrinate them in your ideas
put them in government indoctrination
factories and churn out good little
liberals
and then tell parents they have no
rights because after all you're just
teaching them how to think you're just
teaching them to be broad-minded and
open-minded and to challenge parental
authority but if your authority is
challenged in any way then it's really
bad and by the way we know this is the
case whether it comes from parents or
whether it comes from students you know
many letters i receive from public
school students who say i'm afraid to
speak up in class because my teacher is
going to punish me if i disagree with
the teacher don't give me that high
school teachers are teaching children
how to think in the main they're
teaching their own opinions very often
and where you send your kid is going to
determine what opinions are taught it is
that simple but again the idea here is
the institutions must be upheld and if
that means curbing first amendment
rights fine if it means curbing parental
rights absolutely
the left is simply willing to do this
and standing up is key at this point
they also of course would like to
curtail economic rights as well which is
why they are now pushing an
unconstitutional wealth tax by the way
it is unconstitutional when you hear the
democrats are trying to tax unrealized
gains at the federal level there's
nothing in the constitution that allows
for this
right the the article 1 section 9 of the
constitution of the united states
does not allow for this sort of taxation
which is why you had to have a
constitutional amendment that
constitutional amendment to allow the
income tax only allows the income tax
it does not allow direct taxation of
unrealized gains
but democrats are pushing this because
again economic control ideological
control control over your kids education
do you have did i ever occur to these
people that um maybe we don't want to be
controlled maybe the entire premise of
american liberty is that we are not
controlled and we get to make our own
decisions
and then when you maximize the control
of morons over every aspect of your life
your life gets materially worse i've
been talking a lot in in recent days
about risk and risk allocation about the
fact that human beings tend to want to
minimize risk we don't like risk at the
very least at the very least we don't
like laws
right
and so what we are prone to is handing
over authority to people who pledge that
they are going to minimize our risk but
here's the thing this is what the
institutions are learning and we learn
it anew every time there's a major
unexpected recession for example
you can push off risk you can pretend
that reality entails no risk you can
empower experts to minimize risk but all
they can do is build dams against risk
the waters of risk do not go away the
best way to deal with the endemic risk
in life is to incentivize people to make
good individual decisions in terms of
how to mitigate risk
and maybe local level decisions on how
to deal with risks if they materialize
but when you pledge that you can stop
all risk from happening when you pledge
that if you give somebody complete
informational control they will make
your life better or you give people
complete control over your kids they
will make your life better and your kids
life better
all you're doing is building a dam that
holds back the waters of risk and when
that dam collapses there is a tsunami
not a trickle of risk that is handleable
not a stream of risk that you can tranch
off or that you can redirect or that you
can use to power your economy instead
you create a
damned up flood of risk
and when that dam bursts the risk
overwhelms the entire civilization
and that is what is happening right now
the institutions are cracking those
institutions were damn meant to prevent
you from exercising your freedom to
assess risk
and now as that damn bursts they're
desperately trying to shore it up by
more control it's not going to work
they'd be better off lessening the power
of the water behind the dam by allowing
us to actually make individual
assessments about things that matter to
us by allowing us to speak freely and
access information freely by allowing us
to educate our kids as we see fit but
they're not going to do that because to
do that would
in fact undermine their entire project
which is the control
whether they believe it or not
whether they believe that they are
making your life better if you give them
more control or whether they just want
the power is irrelevant
the effect is that they are going to
control every aspect of your life from
soup to nuts if they have the chance and
they're openly bragging about i mean the
new york times is talking about joe
biden creating cradle to grave welfare
programs the phrase cradle to grave used
to be a pejorative in american politics
it was something the republicans said
about democrats that they wanted cradle
to grave care
demonstrating that they were innovating
the american public
now it's used as a piece of braggadocio
by the left the agenda is pretty much
out there in the open which means that
we have the obligation to fight that
agenda
it's the reason why it is so necessary
to look at what big cities like chicago
are doing right now in implementing
universal basic income and say to
yourself what is this designed to do
except to make people more dependent on
government
except except to continue to foster the
lie that the more control you give these
people the safer they will keep you
they're not going to keep you safe at
all because eventually reality always
intervenes and when it does it gets
really really ugly all right we'll be
back here later today with an additional
hour of content coming up soon the matt
wall show airs at 1 30 pm eastern be
sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the mat wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show